Tom Brady has announced he wants to do
stand up if you're the greatest football
player of all time or if you're a
football player after that only either
be an announcer or open up some sort of
Warehouse that sells suits that's it or
have a restaurant maybe even though
that's kind of annoying but use your
name for something dude stand up comedy
why do people think and I I don't I'm
not one of those guys that thinks that
oh great Tom Gray's doing stand-up this
is the death of stand-up comedy dude I
don't care about that the whole hip-hop
is dead thing is stupid right hip-hop is
real it's just not what's getting the
clicks which is fine
I mean there's still nods out there
doing that thing but it's like
you know Papoose isn't really around
anymore and he was true hip-hop I got a
fitted hat on my head he was real
hip-hop dude Papoose
a fitted hat on my head I got my hater
blockers on block them out what happened
to him man uh Tom Brady is has announced
he wants to do stand-up uh he he's not
doing sports anymore he wants to focus
on his stand-up career which is
hilarious that'd be like like think
about how silly that sounds if I was
just all of a sudden like dude I really
want to focus on my architect career I
don't have one
Tom Brady throws footballs and you don't
have one to be like yeah I really want
to focus I want to focus on my chef
career honestly oh I don't cook dude
he did it zero times a career
I don't know why people get so
successful in their thing and they want
to do something else dude before that
happens to me bury me
because like
you figured out what you do you're the
goat there you go even God up in heaven
is like
I gave him that
Golden Arm
this is so annoying even God is like God
damn it
are you serious Tom oh God I would kill
him but then everyone would
kill him early but then there would be
like a whole thing about it and be so
annoying I'd have to keep watching
specials about it build over the news I
don't
I'm so pissed off
devil can you get your claws in them
I've been working on it
but it just seems so goddamn perfect
so nobody's doing stand-up comedy and
he's talking into like Netflix about
doing
what I do
so anyway you ever been on the 25-yard
line and
oh
yeah
Giselle just at home just getting
pipelate on or you're sorry going out
the other night she was just dancing so
hard man giselle's really a hot ticket
she is right she was out having fun in
like some boxy just dancing around man
when your wife is so hot here's the
thing Tom Brady is the goat when your
wife is so hot and then she and you're
both famous and then she you guys break
up and then you gotta see viral videos
of her doing mom dancing to Mambo Number
Five with like some skater boys oh my
god dude
no wonder who wants to do stand-up
comedy these guys just everyone thinks
they're Joe Rogan they think they could
do anything there's two guys who can do
anything Joe Rogan and Bo Jackson and
where'd Beau end up right
those pictures of him with the football
thing on and he's just
um I mean even Deion Sanders couldn't
really do it all he tried he's good he's
good at announcing but
um
anyway dude Tom Brady's gonna do stand
up can't wait for it can't wait for it
even though I think a black guy should
have that job
congratulations
[Music]